BILL SB FOUR FORTY FOUR WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
SENATOR UMBERG TAKEN AWAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
ALSO- BEFORE THE DAY IS SB FOUR
FOUR FOUR- CONCERNING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN THE
SUPERIOR COURTS- AS YOU KNOW
ALL OF CALIFORNIA IN MANY WAYS
IS IN THE FOREFRONT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN IN
ONE AREA THAT WE WISH TO
EXPLORE IS EFFICIENCIES- IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY USING THE
RESOURCES. IN THIS CASE THAT
DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IRVINE AND
YOU RECEIVE CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY- TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE COURTS TO CREATE A MORE
EFFICIENT SYSTEM ANYMORE JUST
SYSTEM IN PARTICULAR WITH
RESPECT TO FOR EXAMPLE PRO SE
LITIGANTS FOLKS WHO DON'T HAVE
COUNSEL- BUT ARE ENGAGED IN IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. AS WELL AS
JUDGE NOT TOMORROW IT WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS THE PRESIDING
JUDGE THE ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE NOT CAMARO
WE WE'RE TALKING THIS MORNING
ABOUT SOME OTHER AREAS WHERE WE
MIGHT CREATE SOME GREAT
EFFICIENCIES SO FOR EXAMPLE-
WITH RESPECT TO EXPUNGEMENT OF
RECORDS OF WHETHER WE CAN USE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO
AUTOMATICALLY EXPUNGE SOME
RECORDS THAT ARE DESERVING OF
EXPUNGEMENT. WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO THROUGH THE LABORIOUS
PROCESS OF ACTUALLY HAVING
HEARING AND GOING THROUGH THAT
EXERCISE THE SAME THING WITH
RESTRAINING ORDERS THAT- IT IS
POSSIBLE PERHAPS TO EXPEDITE
AND TO CREATE EFFICIENT IS WITH
RESPECT. TO OF RESEARCH IN
ORDER. ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
BUT THE RESIST WELL IS TO CALL
THIS A COLLABORATIVE MAC.
BETWEEN THE COURTS AND- AND TO
SCHOOLS TO DO THAT A JUDGE NT
KOMMER AS BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT
A IN TERMS OF JUDGES.
INTERESTED IN LEADING THIS
EFFORT NEEDS WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF SB FOR.
JUDGE THANK YOU SENATOR OF TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH SO
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE AS YOU MAY
HAVE ALL FOUR MINUTES. WELCOME
THANK YOU HAVE THE CENTERS OF
STAFF- HAPPY NEW YEAR- IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE- SENATE BILL FOUR
FOUR FOUR. I AM THE BLOODY
JUDGE AS INDICATED BY SENATOR
UMBERG OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT- WE ARE THE
THIRD LARGEST COURT IN
CALIFORNIA AND I BELIEVE WE
ARE. PROBABLY THE AT THE MOST
FOR FRONT OF THE A. I.
TECHNOLOGY AND- OF THE STATE WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED- PERSONNEL
IN OUR TAX SECTION WHICH FAR
EXCEEDS HIS BODY OF THE COURT
AND PERHAPS EXCEPT FOR LOS
ANGELES. AND WE JUST WERE
PROVIDED OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANT MONEY TO PROVIDE FOR
CERTAIN- TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS A
CLEANER COURT USUAL PORTAL
WHICH BASICALLY- ALLOWS. A PRO
SE LITIGANTS TO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON AT THE COURT YOUR
CALENDARS IN THE CASE. THAT AS
WELL AS OTHER ITEMS IN TERMS OF
JURY SERVICE WE HAVE- A NEW
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE TO LOOK AT
THEIR APP AND SEE. SOMEONE TO A
JURY THINGS OF THAT NATURE
THESE ARE OF. REASONS WHY ARE
IS AT THE FOREFRONT TECHNO. WE
HAVE A- CORD ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WE ARE LOOKING AT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE GOOGLE
AND SOME OTHER OF VERY
MICROSOFT VERY VERY LARGE-
COMPANIES THAT ARE- IN FACT AT
THE FOREFRONT THE OFFICIAL
DILIGENCE WE'VE TALKED WITH THE
DEAN S
W SCHOOL WHO WISHES TO HAVE
UC IRVINE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN
TERMS OF LAW SCHOOL EDUCATION.
SO WELL WE'VE ALREADY TALKED
WITH THE- A JOE DONE WHOSE ALSO
ON THE- OF THE BOARD OF
VISITORS FOR YOU SEE I LAW
SCHOOL IN THE WE HAVE ALREADY
HAD ONE COURSE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH YOU SO I LAW SCHOOL AND
THEIR STUDENTS. IN WHICH WE
WERE. DEVELOPING A PROGRAM
WHICH WILL ASSIST PRO SE
LITIGANTS IN MAKING AS A CENTER
NUMBER INDICATED- PROTECTIVE OR
APPLICATIONS. WE THINK WE CAN
GO MUCH FURTHER- WITH RESPECT
TO EXPAND ONE ORDERS WE GET
EXPIRED THOSE WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE- WITH RESPECT TO
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN MEANING
THE- ABROGATION OF THE FELONY
MURDER RULE. WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN IMPLEMENT THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN TERMS OF-
PROCESSING THOSE APPLICATIONS
MUCH QUICKER AND THEN IT WOULD
TAKE BOTH OF LOS. LAW CLERKS AS
WELL AS- JUDGES TO PROCESS OVER
TIME AND- IF YOU THE FACT THAT
THE FOURTH DISTRICT HAS.
RECENTLY HELD THAT- FORTY THREE
SEVEN IS NOT ON CONSTITUTION
BASED ON CERTAIN PROPOSITIONS
THAT WERE ARGUABLY INCONSISTENT
WITH THAT. IT APPEARS THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE A HUGE TASK FOR THE
COURT TO PROCEED IN THAT
FASHION LET ME SAY THAT ACCESS
TO THE COURT IS. PROBABLY ONE
OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES OF
OUR COURT INDIVIDUALLY TERMS OF
ONE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT WE
HAD A- A- CONFERENCE OF ALL ALL
BENCH CONFERENCE IN MARCH WE
IDENTIFY THAT AS OUR MAJOR
GOAL. THE CHIEF JUSTICE CAN'T
HEAL SAKE WAY HAS INDICATED
THAT ONE OF HER HIGHS PARTIES
WELL AS USUAL COUNCIL SO. WITH
RESPECT TO USING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WHICH IS A VERY
POWERFUL TOOLAND BRING IN THE
COURSE INTO- THE FOREFRONT OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. IT WOULD BE OF
GREAT BENEFIT WHEN WE WOULD
SHARE THAT BENEFIT WITH THE
OTHER COURTS WHAT WE HAVE ALSO
DONE PREVIOUSLY WHEN WE'VE-
DEVELOP CERTAIN PROJECTS THAT
WOULD- BE BENEFICIAL. TO THAT
THE COURT SYSTEM. SOUNDS GREAT
THANK YOU JUDGE. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. YES OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. YES SENATOR
RAZA THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THE JUDGE ALSO FOR
IF OU COULD GET IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE SINCE I'M- NOT THE
KIND OF PERSON WHO UNDERSTANDS
EVERYTHING ABOUT. ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BUT IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT BETTER HOW
THIS WOULD HELP PEOPLE I KNOW
YOU GAVE EXAMPLES OF
EXPUNGEMENT OF RECORDS AND
RESTRAINING ORDERS MAYBE JURY
SERVICE. BUT IF YOU'RE A
REGULAR. PERSON ON THE STREET
WHAT HOW HOW DO YOU DO THIS AND
WHAT KIND OF TRAINING WOULD IT
TAKE TO DO THIS WE'RE GONNA BE
USING ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
DOES NOT REQUIRE ANOTHER LEVEL
OF UNDERSTANDING DOES REQUIRE
ANOTHER LEVEL OF TRAINING TO
BUILD TO USE THAT. WHO ARE THE
FOLKS WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT THE MOST AND YOU KNOW
MAYBE YOU HAVE REAL STUDIES ON
THIS MAYBE OF JUST PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE BUT- GET INTO THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE FOR ME PLEASE.
I'LL TAKE A CRACK IN THE JUDGE
NOT AMERICAN CORRECT ME- SO. I
THINK FOR EXAMPLE WITH RESPECT
TO PRO SE. LITIGANTS WHO ARE
FACING OF SITUATION DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO. OFTEN TIMES NOT
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL AND THE
THEY THEY HAVE TO FILL OUT A
FORM AND THEN DEMONSTRATE THAT.
THEY'VE HIT THE REQUISITE SORT
OF. BOB REQUISITE LEVEL OF
EVIDENCE THAT KIND OF THING AND
SO IT HELPS BOTH THE APPLICANT.
SAYS THE APPLICANT YOU DID NOT
YOU DON'T TELL US FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN AND WHERE YEAH AND DID
EVENT INVOLVING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OCCURRED SO WE NEED TO
KNOW WHEN AND WHERE AND WHO. IF
YOUR FORM DOESN'T HAVE THAT IT
IT IT SPITS IT BACK OUT AT YOU
AND THEN ON THE OTHER SIDE IT
IS THE BENCH OFFICER THEN WOULD
SEE THE APPLICATION AND IT CAN
ALERT THE BENCH OFFICER ALL
WERE MISSING THIS OR WE HAVE
THIS OR THIS IS YOU CAN'T
CONSIDER THIS YOU KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEYOND. WHAT
WHAT YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER YOU KNOW SAY FOR
EXAMPLE IT LIST SOMEONE SAYS
THEY'VE DONE SOMETHING AND
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT RACE OR
SOMETHING THERE YOU CAN'T
CONSIDER THAT SO OF THAT THAT'S
THAT'S MY VIEW JUDGE YOU GO
YES- WE WOULD HOPEFULLY HAVE
THIS. A I PROGRAM SO THAT WHEN
IT REACHES THE JUDGE THERE'S NO
OBVIOUS DEFECTS AN APPLICATION
LET'S SAY THAT SOMEBODY COMES
INTO A SELF HELP CENTER AND
THERE'S SOME TYPE OF AFTER MANY
TIMES OUR SELF HELP CENTERS ARE
OVERWHELMED WITH. PEOPLE COMING
IN REPRESENTING THEMSELVES AND
THEY NEED IMMEDIATE HELP THEY
COULD SIT DOWN AS AT A COMPUTER
MIGHT HAVE AN AVATAR SOMEBODY
BASICALLY LOOKS LIKE A PERSON
BUT ACTUALLY IS IN A AYE
PERSON. LIAM THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS IS SO WHEN
THEY PUT IN THE FIRST OR SECOND
LINE OF THAT APPLICATION EXT
WILL YOU MISS THIS WITH RESPECT
TO THE PERSON WHO'S BASICALLY
DOING THIS TO YOU YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BURDEN OF
PROOF IS ACTS. I AM THE ARE YOU
STILL WANT TO GO FORWARD WITH
THIS SO THEY UNDERSTAND. IN THE
APPLICATION IS X. Y. Z. WHAT
TIMES THE- SELF HELP CENTER
PERSON DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
EXPLAIN IT TO THEM. AND
DOESN'T. BASICALLY GO THROUGH
EVERY ELEMENT OF WHAT THEY NEED
TO HAVE IN THEIR APPLICATION
AND GOES LINE BY LINE IN TERMS
OUR APPLICATION. AND BY THE
TIME THAT IT'S COMPLETED. NOT
ONLY DOES THE APPLICANT FEEL
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT THAT
APPLICATIONS GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT FOR A JUDGE TO GRANT
A PROTECTIVE ORDER WITH RESPECT
LESZEK VIOLENCE. BUT ALSO THE
JUDGE WILL FEEL THE SAME WAY
AND- THE APPLICANT FEELS THAT-
THEY THEY HAVE MET THE BURDEN
OF PROOF. TO GET A PROTECTIVE
ORDER WHICH PREVENTS THEM FROM
BEING. A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THE WHAT SOMETIMES IT
DOES NOT IN THEIR LOWER TO
PRACTICE BUT I HAVE OBSERVED IS
THAT AN APPLICANT WILL HAVE AN
INSUFFICIENT APPLICATION THE
COURT THE BENCH ALSO LOOK AT
AND SAY I'M SORRY THIS
APPLICATION IS INSUFFICIENT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO COME BACK
WELL THAT THAT DOESN'T WORK
WELL FOR THE COURTS OR FOR THE
FOR THE APPLICANT- WITH RESPECT
TO EXPUNGEMENT THERE THERE ARE
CERTAIN. OUR RECORDS THAT ARE
ENTITLED TO EXPUNGEMENT BUT IF
THE PERSON WHO- DOESN'T KNOW
THAT THAT THERE AND HAVE THE
EXPUNGEMENT- THEORETICALLY A I
WILL IDENTIFY YOU KNOW THESE OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THAT
NOW CAN HAVE THE RECORDS
EXPUNGED FOR CERTAIN OFFENSES.
WELL. AND IT HELP YET JUST I'M
SORRY. IS THIS THE VERY FIRST
TIME THE IT'S GOING TO BE DONE
ANYWHERE IN A CORD OR IS THERE
SOME VERSION THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN TRIED- WHERE WHERE DO WE
STAND AS FAR AS. I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY- A. R. PROGRAM WITH
RESPECT TO. PROTECTIVE ORDERS I
KNOW I KNOW THAT WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED WORKING ON THIS LIST TO
THE UC IRVINE LAW STUDENTS AND
BASICALLY- GENERATING THIS TYPE
OF PROGRAM. WITH RESPECT TO UP
THE EXPUNGEMENT ORDERS AGAIN-
WE ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
THESE ARE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ALREADY GENERATED
THESE ARE. VERY WOULD BE VERY
SOPHISTICATED WITH RESPECT TO
OF WHAT WE WOULD HAVE TO LOOK
AT TWO WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
THIS PERSON TO TILE TO EXPUNGE
WHEN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE POINT.
SO ON. THIS IS WHY. WE NEED THE
FUNDING WHO- THE COURTS ARE
OPERATING AT A SITUATION WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS OF. TAX
STAFF TO TAKE CONSERVE CERTAIN
PROJECTS SUCH AS THIS- WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
DO IT. IT'S JUST HAVING THE
FUNDING AND THE PERSON POWER TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT IT. THANK
YOU I'M A REP FOR JUST A
SECOND- WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
LEYVA HERE FLAVOR HERE WILK
CHIANG RUSSELL. RUSSELL HERE
GLAZER. GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE
PAN. PAN HERE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS HEARD RIGHT
NOW I JUST TO COMMENT THAT- I
MEAN THIS THE CONCEPT OF IT
OBVIOUSLY SOUNDS REALLY GREAT-
A LOT MORE QUESTIONS AND WE'LL
JUST KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT.
MARCUS AND- IT IT JUST A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. BUT POSITIVE
QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
THEY'RE PAN I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- SIR BURGER
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS BILL-
FRONT OF US A DO YOU HAVE I DO
A SO HAVE MANY SEVERAL
QUESTIONS SENATOR ALSO I IT'S
BECAUSE THE FIRST QUESTION IS
BY MOST PERTINENT TO ADD
COMMITTEE IS THAT. IT'S USUALLY
FAIRLY UNUSUAL FOR US TO. AT
THE END SENSE TO ITS FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT TO
ALLOCATE MONEY DIRECTLY TO A
SUB PART OF YOU SEE AND NOT YOU
SEE AS A WHOLE SO- IS IT IS
THERE'S SO OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
LAW SCHOOL SO THEY HAVE LEGAL
EXPERTISE- IS THAT WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING TO SPUR THE LAW
SCHOOL AND WHY THESE LAW
SCHOOLS IS THERE SOME SERVICE
CAPACITY THAT THEY HAVE BEYOND
THEIR LEGAL EXPERTISE- IN TERMS
OF IN TECHNICAL. CAPACITY THAT-
THOSE PARTICULAR LAW SCHOOLS
VERSUS HAVING YOU KNOW
BASICALLY CHARGING YOU SEE TO
DO THIS ARE WE PLAINTIFFS ARE
THESE LAW SCHOOLS ON
CONTRACTORS OUT TO A TECH
COMPANY A SO HOW HOW HOW'S THIS
POST THE- VISION TO WORK SO
THANK YOU CENTER PAN FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS- QUESTION NUMBER ONE
THE MONEY QUESTION YOU'RE RIGHT
WE CAN'T THIS BE AMENDED WE
CAN'T WE APPROPRIATE MONEY THE
RECEIPT CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU
KNOW THEY ARE SEPARATE
SOVEREIGN NATION- AND THAT THAT
THEY DECIDE HOW MONEY IS TO BE
SPENT SO THIS. WHAT WE'RE NOT
THE BILL. DIRECT THIS. ARM WE
ARE HOPEFUL AND WORKING WITH
THE RIVER. THIS HAPPENS THIS IS
A COLLABORATIVE INITIATIVE THAT
I THINK IS A GREAT DEAL OF
MERIT. AND I'M HOPEFUL AND I.
HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THEY'LL
SEE THE MERIT IN THIS THIS
PROPOSAL AS NUMBER ONE. NUMBER
TWO IN TERMS OF THE TO LAW
SCHOOLS- THERE IS A CALIFORNIA
IRVINE IS JUDGE NOT KOMMER
INDICATOR THERE'S BEEN VAULT IN
THIS AREA FOR SOMETIME AND IN
THEIR SEEKING. THE DEAN IN
PARTICULAR DâN SONG IS.
SEEKING TO BE- IN THE FOREFRONT
AMONG ALL LAW SCHOOLS IN THE
COUNTRY. IN THE AREA OF A AYE
IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND SO IT
WAS REALLY AT THEIR INITIATIVE
THAT THAT THIS BEGAN- NEVER SEE
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY DEAN
CHAMBER IN SKI NEVER TO LAG
BEHIND ANY OTHER SCHOOL OF THE
HIS CHIMED IN AND SAID HE- HE
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE AS WELL.
THE RATIONALE IS THAT IF YOU
THERE'S FIVE YEARS UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA LAW SCHOOLS. IF
WE'RE SPREAD TOO THIN- THEN WE
WON'T REALLY BE ABLE TO FOCUS
EFFORTS AND SO THAT THAT'S THE
RATIONALE BUT IS THERE SOME
SORT TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO THE
ANY GET I DON'T. THAT SPREAD
EVENLY MODEL IT DOES NOT
GRAMMAR RESPONDED BUT I BUT I
THINK THE AT THE SHORT ANSWER
IS. THAT THEY DO HAVE CERTAIN
LEGALLY THIESSEN SOME TECHNO
THEY THEY HAVE TECHNICAL. FOLKS
ON FACULTY AT UCI THAT THAT ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN IMPLEMENTING
YES JUDGE AT THE CENTER AND
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION. I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU'RE HERE FOR I
EXPLAINED IN TERMS OF WAR
TENNIS ARTICLE WORK. YES BUT WE
ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE COURT YSTEM
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED.
PERSONNEL WITH RECESS SO I
THOUGHT MAYBE JUST AS OUR CUT
TO THE CHASE THEN OKAY THE-
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE WOULD BE
THROUGH THE- COURTS AND ORANGE
COUNTY ARE WITH B. B.
CONTRACTING OUT WELL. LOU
BECAUSE IT SAY I RIGHT YEAH I
HAVEN'T FINISHED IT BUT I'M
NOT. WITH RESPECT TO YOU WE
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH GOOGLE
WELL. AS A MICROSOFT. THOSE
HUGE RELATIONSHIP SO WE HAVE
ALREADY EXISTING. THAT WE CAN
TAP INTO THAT WE'VE ALREADY
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP AND ALSO
THEY COULD. PROVIDE US WITH
SOME EXPERTISE THAT WE NEEDED.
IN ADDITION WITH RESPECT TO UC
IRVINE LOS AUTORES SPEAK TO
BECAUSE I'M ON THE BOARD OF
VISITORS. OF THE WE HAVE A JOE
DON WHO IS BASICALLY A IN A
TRACTOR WITH RESPECT TO. IT OUR
FREEWILL TELLIGENT IS ALSO. A
PROFESSIONAL STAFF IS NAME
ESCAPES ME. BUT THE ON AT UC
IRVINE LAW SCHOOL WHO IS IT AN
EXPERT IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HE WAS PART OF THE
FOR ME. REGULATION OF THE
WATSON PROGRAM IF YOU SAW THAT.
YEAH ELLE BASICALLY- FOR IBM
SO- THERE IS CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF EXPERTISE I THINK
THAT WITH RESPECT OR CHORDS
WELL AS THE LOSS OKAY ALL
RIGHT. AND THEN- BUT YOUR
INTELLIGENCE BUT I DON'T SON TO
DO STRAIGHT I'M NOT ATTORNEY
BUT IT SINCE WE'RE TALKING A
AYE AND I HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE
OR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT A AYE AND
HEALTH CARE. AND SO IT SOUNDS
SEXY WILL AND DO A I TO HELP US
SORT OUT THESE THINGS. A YET SO
FIRST OF ALL THE TIME BUT
PLEASE SEE HERE JUDGE BECAUSE
IT BECAUSE OF MY OF MY
QUESTIONS WAS IS THAT WHILE IS
DID YOU DO CHAU COUNCIL ALL ON
BOARD BECAUSE YOU CREATE A
TOLL. AND YOU KNOW OUR THE
JUDGE IS GOING TO USE IT RIGHT
ALREADY HAS A I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT BLACK BOX OKAY SO I GUESS
IS A COUPLE QUESTIONS RELATED
AYE ONE IS THE BLACK BOX
ASPECT. IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY
USING ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
BECAUSE THAT'S A QUESTION LIKE-
YOU KNOW YOU YOU DO THE NEURAL
NETWORKS WHATEVER ELSE BUT
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON INSIDE
RIGHT IN FACT SOME STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT WHEN YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
INSIDE ESSENTIALLY YOUR AND
BEDDING AND THIS IS PERHAPS
IMPOSE RELEVANT TO THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM. IT'S ALREADY BEEN A
PROBLEM HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY IN BED CERTAIN
BIASES AND SO FORTH BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY WE'VE ALWAYS
DONE THINGS YES YOU BAKE IT
INTO THE PROGRAM. OKAY SO. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THIS PROJECT WON'T
WORK BUT AGAIN SOMETHING TO BE
VERY AWARE ABOUT THAT. IT NEEDS
TO BE ESPECIALLY I THINK IT IS
A PROCESS. WHATEVER PROCESS
THIS. PROGRAM IS A AYE PROGRAMS
GOING TO BE. NEED T BE VERY
TRANSPARENT WHAT'S GOING ON
YOU'LL GET INPUT OUTPUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN BETWEEN. IS THE-
WELL THERE'S A NEURAL NETWORK
AND ITS LIKE THAT AT ABOUT
SEVEN IN AND OUT YOU HAVE TO
BEFORE YOU USE IT SAY. I HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY HOW THIS
PROGRAM IS MAKING DECISION.
THAT I PUT THIS INPUT IN.
LEADING TO THAT RECOMMENDATION.
BECAUSE IT IS IT IS YOU
MENTIONED A JUDGE OR SOMEONE'S
GONNA BE. EXPECTING TO MAKE
DECISIONS BASED. RECOMMENDATION
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THAT BLACK BOX IN BETWEEN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING OUT WELL
IT'S THE A. I. PROGRAM. SHE
JUST YOU KNOW PROBABLY DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT. THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE RATE. TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS AN EVENT- WE ACTUALLY
DID HAVE WE'VE MET SEVERAL
TIMES WE HAD A HEARING IN
ORANGE COUNTY WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND YOU YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED ONE OF THE KEY
CONCERNS IS. IMPLICIT BIAS- AND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO OUR BEST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
IMPLICIT BIAS ONE OF THE
SAFEGUARDS THOUGH IS THAT. SO
JUST USING THE EXAMPLE OF A
PROTECTIVE ORDER RESTRAINING
ORDER IS THAT ULTIMATELY A
BENCH OFFICER HAS TO MAKE THAT
DECISION SO IN OTHER WORDS THE
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A BLACK
BOX THAT MAKES A DECISION. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WHATEVER
POPS OUT IN TERMS OF JUDGE YOU
NEED TO YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE
FOLLOWING ARE YOU SERIOUS ARE
WE ARE WE MISSING THIS
CRITERIA- THAT THAT THAT THAT'S
A THAT'S AN IMPORTANT CONCERN.
THAT THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH
AWARE OF- WE SHOULDN'T. IN MY
VIEW THOUGH. OF A PARTICULAR
WITH RESPECT TO PRO SE
LITIGANTS. OF WHO. WE SHOULDN'T
LOVE. WE SHOULD DELAY THINGS BE
BECAUSE THE PRO SE LITIGANTS
RIGHT NOW ARE BEING IMPACTED BY
THE IN FISH IN MY VIEW THE IN
INEFFICIENCIES OF THE CURRENT
SYSTEM SO I THINK WE CAN
OVERCOME. ANY ISSUE CONCERNING
IMPLICIT BIAS BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE MECHANISM BUT ALSO IN TERMS
THE SAFEGUARDS OKAY WELL SICKER
YEAH IS THAT I'M HEARING RIGHT
DOCUMENT FOR IS OF COURSE WE
HAVE THIS PRESSURE. ON THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM- OF COURSE
JUSTICE DELAYED IS OFTEN
JUSTICE DENIED HOW DO WE MOVE
THINGS ALONG WE CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO HELP DO
THIS. BUT ESPECIALLY IN THE
PRESSURE OF TIME. THE PROGRAM
MAKES A RECOMMENDATION THE
JUDGE SAYS OKAY THAT'S
RECOMMENDATION I'M SURE WILL
STILL CONSIDER OTHER FACTORS
BUT IN THE PRESSURE OF TIME MAY
SAY OKAY LET'S JUST SWEEP
THROUGH THESE YOU KNOW OF A
PROGRAM THAT SCANNED THROUGH
THE PROGRAM AT SOMETHING BUILT
IN AND WE DON'T KNOW IT THAT'S
MY THING IS WE NEED TO HAVE THE
NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENT HOW IT
GOT FROM POINT A OF. A TO POINT
B. AND THAT'S WHEN THE
CHALLENGES AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE THE
MECHANISM THE REASONS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
BECAUSE THE OTHER SOME INTERNAL
PROCESS BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
TRANSPARENT HOW IT GETS FROM
THIS INPUT SAID INPUTS LEAD TO
THOSE SET OF OUTLETS AND THAT.
BOX AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE
COMPANIES THAT MIGHT ONE MAKING
PROPRIETARY YET SAY NO NO NO NO
NO IT HAS TO BE BLOWN OPEN HAS
TO BE OPENED TO EXAMINATION BY
PEOPLE TO BE SURE THAT OTHER
OUTSIDE OTHER ENTITIES CAN LOOK
AT IT AND SAY WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT ACTUALLY THERE MAY BE A
PROBLEM HERE AND WE NEED TO
FIND A WAY TO ADJUST FOR THAT
RIGHT. SO IT CAN'T BE
PROPRIETARY HAS TO BE OPEN
ENDED SB TRANSPARENT PEOPLE
NEED TO BUILD BASICALLY WORK.
DIVE INTO AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
EXACTLY IS THAT PROGRAM DOING-
AND I CAN GIVE YOU I WON'T
SPEND TIME HERE DOING EXAMPLES
IN HEALTH CARE WHERE THINGS
HAVE YOU KNOW ACTUALLY THE WHEN
THEY FINALLY BROKE UP IN THE
BOX MADE DECISIONS REALLY BASED
ON THINGS THAT WERE NOT
APPROPRIATE- AND THEN I GUESS
FINALLY I WOULDJUST MAKE A
THIS IS JUST A FROM MY
EXPERIENCE COMMENT AGAIN
PRIVATE MORE. PREVENTION
APPROPRIATE DID YOU SURE IT I
APPRECIATE DID YOU KNOW IS
USING PROGRAM TO MAKE SOME OF
THESE HAVE THINGS HAPPEN I ALSO
KNOW TALKING TO SOME NO NOT THE
LEGAL STAFF LIKE LOCKERS AND
THE JUDGES BUT FRONTLINE STAFF
IN A CERTAIN COURT SYSTEMS THAT
BASE SOME BEEN TOLD THEY CAN'T
TELL CLIENTS ARE HEALTH PLANS
THANKS HEY YOU KNOW YOU FORGOT
THEY- ARE. ALSO THE CAN ONLY
ACCEPT A FORM SO I HOPE THAT
DID YOU FEEL COUNSEL ALSO
LOOKING AT FREEING YOUR FRONT
LINE STAFF TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO ASSIST PEOPLE NOT WITH LEGAL
ADVICE AT. IT PEOPLE HAVE. STE
PHIL AND- SPACE FORMER PUMPING
ACTUALLY Là POINT IT OUT TO
PEOPLE. AND NOT BE PUNISHED FOR
THAT BECAUSE I'M FOR I HAVE
THAT FROM PEOPLE. FROM FRONT
MIGHT STAFF THAT THEY'VE BEEN
TOLD THAT THAT'S COOL THE
PRACTICE OF LAW TO POINT OUT
THIS FOOT SOMEONE FORGOT TO
DATE THE FORM. THEY JUST HAVE
TO ACCEPT IT AND THEY GET A
LETTER SAYING HEY YOU DIDN'T
EAT YOUR FORMER REJECTING A
REFILE IT. AND HOPEFULLY SO
THAT'S ASIDE ROM A AYE BUT
THAT'S YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT THOSE TYPES AND
EFFICIENCIES ARE LIMITED AS
WENT. AND THAT WHAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER OF THAT THAT
IS A COMMON ISSUE IS WHERE
SOMEONE FEELS AN APPLICATION
AND- PRESUMABLY. THIS IS NOT
QUITE ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
THIS IS WHERE WHEE YOU DIDN'T
PUT IN THE DATE AND RIGHT
PROGRAM SAYS OH YOU CAN'T
SUBMIT THIS BECAUSE IN PUT A
DATE RATHER. THAN APPEARING
BEFORE THE BENCH OFF THEIR
BENCH OFFICES OGLE GOODNESS
GRACIOUS. I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DETAIL HERE ABOUT WHATEVER
EVENT. IS NOT PRECIPITATED YOU
COMING TO COURT ASKING FOR
PROTECTIVE ORDER. YOU COME BACK
TOMORROW OKAY THE THAT. THAT IF
WE CAN CREATE EFFICIENCY WHERE
THE FORM ACTUALLY SAYS YOU YOU
KNOW YOU HAVEN'T MET THE BURDEN
OF PROOF YOU NEED MORE
INFORMATION. A JUDGE. YES I
CERVANTES IDENTIFY PROBABLY THE
MOST. A CRUCIAL CONCERN WITH
RESPECT TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WITH RESPECT TO
BIAS IT'S GOING TO SHOW THE
BIASES THE PERSON ACTUALLY
PROGRAM THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE SITUATION- WITH
RESPECT TO- JUDICIAL DECISIONS
IT'S AGAINST THE- USUAL ETHICS
TO WERE. BASICALLY WHAT A
COMPUTER MAKE THAT DECISION YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE UNDERLYING
FACTS IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
DECISION A WITH RESPECT TO MANY
OF WHAT JUDGES DO AND I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU'RE AWARE OF THIS
MANY OF ITS TO IS BASED ON.
WORK UP DONE BY LEGAL RESEARCH
PEOPLE ALL OF THE CLERICAL AND-
SOMETIMES THE COPIES OF THOSE
STAFF AND VERY STRONG MENTALLY
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN BIASES AND
I THINK WITH RESPECT TO A
DECISIONS AND WHAT THEY FEEL IS
IMPORTANT TO BRING THAT TO THE
JUDGE. MAY BE MORE OF. OTHER
CONSERVE THAN USING A AYE WITH
RESPECT TO- HAVE A GROUP OF
JUDGES SAYING WE NEED TO LOOK
AT ALL THESE THINGS IN ORDER TO
HAVE A COMPLETE WORK UP TO GIVE
TO THE JUDGE BECAUSE THAT
PERSON MAY HAVE HAD A BAD DAY
AND HAD SOMETHING WITH RESPECT
TO A PERSON OF CERTAIN TYPE OF-
RACIAL BACKGROUND WHEN THEY SEE
THAT PERSONS OF THE
APPLICATION. OF THEY MIGHT SAY
WELL GOSH I'M NOT GOING TO
REALLY GIVE THIS OF THE A
DEGREE OF IMPORTANCE THAT IT
DOES WELL WE GET IN A AYE
SITUATION OF THAT TYPE OF BIAS
THAT MIGHT COME INTO THAT TYPE
OF DECISION MAKING IS NOT THERE
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
REPLACING A- PERSON WHO MIGHT
HAVE THEIR OWN BIASES WITH A
COMPUTER. SYSTEM THAT. PERHAPS
WHAT IS SUPERIOR BECAUSE IT.
BASICALLY LOOKS AT MORE FACTORS
IT'S NOT A SUBJECT TO THE WITH
THE MOTION OF A PERSON WHO THE
JUDGES OBVIOUSLY SOMETIMES WILL
RELY UPON. AND THE BUT I THINK
WITH RESPECT TO BE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND LOOKING AT
ALL THE FACTORS IF WE HAVE THE
PROPER PROGRAM AND WE ARE AWARE
AND OF BECOME VERY AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT THERE COULD BE BIASES
PLACED AND I THINK THAT MIGHT
BE A SUPERIOR SIT SITUATION IN
ORDER TO MAKE A DECISION OKAY
WELL I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION OF IT AGAIN I
THINK MY CONCERN WAS I
UNDERSTAND THAT CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW HAVING A PERSON COULD HAVE
THEIR OWN BIASES. THAT'S MY
EMPHASIS WAS ON TRANSPARENCY
ESPECIALLY USING A AYE SO BEING
BE OF THE KNOW HOW YOU GOT FROM
INPUT TWO OUTPUT RIGHT IS THE
THING THAT I'M CALLING FOR NOT
SAYING THAT WE CAN'T USE A AYE
BUT I'M JUST SAYING THAT TOO
OFTEN A I IT IS A BLACK BOX IN
BETWEEN AND OR FOR VARIOUS
REASONS SOMETIMES. THING IS
PROPRIETARY SOMETHING ELSE AND
WE'RE GONNA USE INDEED USUAL
SYSTEM IT NEEDS TO BE
TRANSPARENT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO TRACE HOW. THESE INPUTS LED
TO THAT OUTPUT SO CAN
UNDERSTAND AND THEN MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT TO THE PROGRAM. THE
TRY TO REMOVE THE BIAS OF THEIR
WE IN THAT A FIGHT WITH THANK
YOU. YES THE AS I THINK. SET
TRANSPARENCY IS IMPORTANT. AND
I THINK BY HAVING A AYE PROGRAM
YOU CAN'T BE MORE TRANSPARENT.
BECAUSE I THINK JUDGES WOULD BE
VERY HESITANT TO. TO DISCLOSE
WHO THEY RELIED UPON WITH
RESPECT TO A LOCK WORKS OR A
LEGAL RESEARCH OPINION. LESS
THAN THEY WERE ABLE THAT THE
COURT WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A THIS IS OUR A OUR PROGRAM
THIS IS WHAT WE DO IN ORDER TO
MAKE A DECISION. VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT.
YES PLEASE JUST. IN TERMS OF
HOW WHAT THIS MEANS SO. IT'S
REQUESTING THAT. THE UC. SYSTEM
HOUSE RESOLUTION. TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS BUT THEN WERE
COMMITTING TO IS. TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. WELL GO FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THAT THE MONEY THE
MONEY PART BECAUSE WE CAN'T AS
I MENTIONED WE CAN'T DIRECT THE
SOVEREIGN STATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA TO SPEND
THIS MONEY IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA THIS IS THE EXPRESSION ONE
OF OUR INTENT- INTO WE BOTH
INTENT IN TERMS OF THE- OF
STRUCTURE AND INTENT IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE HOPE THEY SPEND THE
MONEY AND WE'LL WORK WITH THEM
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. YEAH. VERY
GOOD SERRA MERCURY LIKE
CLOTHES- I THINK EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SAID HAS BEEN SAID
SO AND WE'RE DONE THEY ARE VERY
MUCH BETTER CHEN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
TO ROSAMOND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LEYVA. AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK CHANGE TO WRESTLE.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I. ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE THREE
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
SORRY I'M SO SORRY ONE ONE. I
HAVE TO REDO THAT I'M I
APOLOGIZE I HAVE TO SAY THAT
IT'S GOING TO HOUSE TO
JUDICIARY SO WE'RE GONNA REDO
THAT BOAT ITEM ONE SB FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY- LEYVA BY LEYVA AYE
WILK CHIANG. RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. PAN AYE.
RIGHT WE HAVE THREE VOTES STILL
AND BELIEVE THIS YEAH. YOU KNOW
START A NEW TREND BUT THANK YOU
CENTER AMBER THANK YOU JUDGE
AND WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
OTHER BOATS
. GLAZER THANK YOU
FOR COMING SO PROMPTLY- MA'AM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM ONE AS BEFORE FOR
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED YOU
JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I BY SURE HASN'T VOTED WILK
CHIANG GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE THINKCENTRE GLAZER
.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM ONE SB FOUR FOUR FOUR
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED YOU
JUDICIARY WITH LEYVA VOTING I
FACED. CHAIR VOTING I'VE VICE
CHAIR NOT LOADING- WILK CHIANG
MCGUIRE. THE BILL IS OUT FOR
TWO ZERO THANKS EVERYBODY HAVE
A GREAT DAY